tell us about the genesis of this
project best-selling book Bryan
Stevenson incredible story how did this
film come to be I think about four or
five years ago
my agency passed me this uh this book
was memoir from Bryan Stevenson and I
started to read it and and I was a
little shocked that I didn't know a
little embarrassed rather than know who
he was so I ran towards that I watched
his TED talk I got a chance to meet him
and we yeah I wanted him to be a
household name it was one of those
things that his work was so important
this man was so was was a really really
great important important person so I
wanted to make the film to really put
his his story in front of as many eyes
as possible so we start to develop the
script got a chance to get to know him
Bryan was very involved in the process
of crafting this story his memoir is
very dense you know it's a lot of lot of
cases that he had in there so we started
to pick out what would make the best
cinematic version of his life and yeah
years later schedule ins lined up you
know got a chance to sit 8:00 to get
Jaime on board a phenomenal phenomenal
phenomenal actor who I got a chance to
it's really embody Walter McMillian and
then yeah we went on shot it down in
Atlanta so that's great it was a great
process 2014 memoir a hundred and fifty
weeks in the New York Times bestseller
list and Counting
and then you're brought in by daniel
quentin to help on the adaptation how
did you approach the project yeah it's
really kind of a unique and interesting
adaptation process for me as a
screenwriter I'd worked with destin
cretton before on the glass castle I
actually met him through the Academy
when we both won the nickel fellowship
at the same time so the producer
gillnetter had was the first person to
give Destin the book and he read it and
just told me about the kind of
transformative like power of the
material and I read it and agreed and
one of the things I was really struck by
was I don't know if you've seen Justin's
other movies but there's a real kind of
warmth and humanity while looking at
kind of institutionalized systems in our
country through the lens of family and
hope and I really felt like Destin's
vision for film and general matched
Brian Stevenson's voice and vision for
the world and for the changes we need to
see in our justice system
so I thought having the relationship
with Destin that I could help help
hopefully and translating translating
that to the screen we also I don't think
Destin ever would have taken the project
if we didn't know that Brian was going
to be really heavily involved with the
adaptation process right right from the
beginning so we always kind of knew that
he would be our sort of guiding light
throughout the entire process yeah so
tell us you know how you approach work
in general and what was special about
this project in terms of are you in the
room with the directors or you get out
and I'ma do this or how does this work
and you yeah well this is my third
collaboration with Destin I saw him out
because I saw his short film short term
12 and it blew me away
and I saw that he deaded it himself so I
thought maybe there's an opening there
and I saw him sought him out and kind of
showed my foot in the door and he had
never worked with editor before so at
first on that film it was really hard
for him not to be at the keyboard I
think he wanted to rest the keyboard
away from you and do it himself and over
the time our relationship and
collaboration is just grown it's just
come better and better and better
to her in this film he just you know
gave me so much empowerment to you know
working with our composer it was really
5050 between me and him and if you know
a little bit of reshoots I was in there
writing them with him and it's just
become a really great collaboration
together and and he loves the editing
process so he's so after a production
you know I'll be off on my own cutting
it I'll show him about a week a week
afterwards and then from there he's
sitting next to me every day and we go
through it so coming to Jamie Foxx so
Johnny D an important story this arc
take really give us Bryan Stevenson's
impact and work you know how do you
prepare for this role and what you learn
in that preparation oh well preparing
for the role what's interesting about
Johnny first of all I I have to think
Michael B Jordan for what he did behind
and in front of the camera when I got
that call um that he was doing this
movie I thought was fantastic and the
fact that if you look at Michael
Jordan's career and I've known him since
he was you know
smaller tiny didn't have all this I
don't know where this came from
but I remember he used to have a little
tank top and braids you know just sort
of a Hawaiian Michael vision how's it
Prada
but what I've admired is his career in
the trajectory of his career if you look
at what he did in Fruitvale station he
captured all of our hearts in that but
that narrative for our culture was
amazing and then to move on from that
and go to black panther where he plays
kill monger to me top three villain but
was he a villain because the narrative
that he had for our culture was amazing
and now to to to just mercy I you know
he could be doing any movie that he
wants biggest star in the world but to
do something like this is is so
necessary I want to say that and also
Walter McMillian we aesthetically looked
like each other our cheekbones we had
the diamond-shaped head if you look at
the end of it that that that that 80's
haircut I had that in 80's so that part
was is welcoming when you're trying to
do a person who's lived and then we sat
together myself
Michael Destin and we sort of crafted
what he would talk like what he was
sound like I would try different accents
I'm from Texas and if you deeper Texas
some people say Tess's so we prodded
with different like ways to say words
and vernacular and things like that and
and I would I would pay attention to
Michael because he was steering the ship
along with us and saying let's make sure
we can understand everything we'll make
sure everything that uh that is being
said that people can can really
understand the weight of the character
and then when it comes to to Walter
McMillian the person it's all about
perception I mean you know it's trying
to change the perception of what a black
man is that the perception is is that
he's automatically guilty my father went
to jail for $25 worth of illegal
substance for seven years a man who had
taught in the hood for 25 years he
taught black studies the very judge that
he would bring
to the school to talk to the kids
presiding this case when they put him in
jail for seven years he was in jail with
people that he had taught in school but
they didn't know that that father taught
me how to play tennis they didn't know
that he taught me how to throw a
football you know he taught me how to
how to swim so I could really draw up on
that because I had a thing about going
to jails I don't I don't like doing that
I don't like going to see people in jail
I don't like that perception so that's
what this was about and then when
luckily my father while he was in I said
hey I wrote him one letter I said hey I
got on when you get out things are
better and I got a chance to take him to
the US Open and watch Venus play so it
was that relationship that I used to
sort of put in place of what Walter and
his family was was going through so
Michael coming back to you in terms of
the the role so you know I'm gonna write
a book about my life and I'm gonna you
know my work and let's see i'ma get
Michael B Jordan to play me that might
work out so so thinking about it how did
you become attached to Brian what was
that relationship like in terms of
knowing you're playing him but also
bringing the movie along in this book to
life what was that relationship what I
think one of the things that you know me
and Destin really kind of decided on was
the tone of the movie and and what type
of portrayal we were gonna do we did
want to do the movie version of anything
we wanted to do an accurate accurate
depiction of this man's life and the
work that he that he does so I got a
chance to get to know him spend time
with him he was extremely busy man but
he we would have meetings and you know
and hang out a little bit I would go
down to his offices down in Montgomery
Alabama and he would you know leave me
and go straight into the Supreme Court
you know and and and and and defend
these these inmates and fight these
cases that are literally life and death
and then he'll pick up the phone and
call me and ask me how I've seen what
you know so he was multitasking on the
high
level possible so to be able just to UM
just to be in his space you know be a
fly on the wall and learn and watch him
move I think the geography of a
courtroom was something that I was very
unfamiliar with I didn't spend many time
in courtrooms that you know I kind of
you know connect that institution with
negative negativity you know you don't
want to catch yourself in there so to
switch that outlook into a position of
power somebody who's defending live
somebody who's fighting for justice in
these rooms was something very
interesting to me so the way he
questioned a witness or the way he you
know just as his body language how he
had to be very persuasive you know there
was a lot of times throughout this film
were my personal natural reaction my you
know natural acting choice would be -
would be to be emotional or outraged and
and and show that you know emotion
through my performance but Brian is very
reserved very methodical very very uh
he's intentional with everything that he
says he knows that he has to put his ego
in his prior to the side for the
betterment of his client and that's
something that that we had to that was a
choice that we had to make but yes so
that all that kind of combined with him
always being you know available via text
or phone for me to kind of ask any
questions whenever I felt lost
throughout the phone so the prison
scenes of those in a prison are those
unset how are you all shooting the
actual prison scenes yeah you are in a
prison or you on a soundstage or yeah we
were in a prison here in the prison um
which is you know it's just daunting you
know I don't I don't like any of that
right I'll dig none of that [ __ ] you
know it's crazy it's like we went in
there and I want to just sort of be
going there for the first time and sort
of hit the ground running that's what we
did we had to go and run it but there
were certain little things that you know
I mean even when the guy was putting the
cuffs on me
there was the of course the person who's
playing the correctional officer but
there was an actual correctional officer
there or officer who's telling him how
to put the cuffs on so he said you know
put the cuffs on tighter he's a bigger
one and I said hey man cuffs is tight
enough
and but you know I was like but I use
that when you go in those prison which
is weird because it's like you know like
I said this is all perception and those
was the perception of seeing a black man
going to jail is just you know Adam I
never wanted to get used to it so I took
that not getting used to it into the
scene like no matter what I still know
this is not a place where I'm supposed
to be or Walters supposed to be or
anybody is supposed to be so you know
working in the the actual jail cell
brings a lot of a lot of emotions you
know so we will bring music in we play
music you know we play no weapon formed
against us shall prosper but then we
will play some you know some Marvin Gaye
and some hip-hop just to sort of you
know lightning cuz this it you know it's
a heavy it's a heavy thing when you're
in there and there's so many moments of
micro but macro aggression in this film
and particularly as black men facing
this both behind bars and and sort of
trapped in the not trapped in this album
he's chosen to be there okay you talk a
bit about sort of why this movie now and
what you what you're hoping it speaks to
to people yeah I think it's extremely
important you know this case happened
over 30 years ago but it seems like it
couldn't happen yesterday you know the
system has been broken and continued to
see that like you know with all the news
headlines and every other incident that
happens with the police and you know
wrongful convictions that you see as you
see throughout the the media I think I
think Brian's optimism is extremely
important I think his hopeful nature on
how to change the perception of what it
looks like to be black and brown and the
skin the anxiety that you know we feel
just walking outside of our homes you
know that that the feeling of when we
see a cop drive-by you know the talk
that my parents had to give me at a very
young age of how to deal with law
enforcement to deal how to care of
yourself it's something that still
happens today and I think Brian's
approach to things through his work is
bringing the humanity you know being in
close proximity some of these places
these towns they only deal with
certain people through media through
what they see on their televisions
through through you know the movies they
watch through the the you know the media
outlasted the news so if we use those
same outlets to change the perception
that we might be able to you know find
the humanity and one another as the
people and and that's why I want people
to feel after watching this movie that
the energy of they could be a part of
the solution you know I think these
issues sometimes seems so big that it's
paralyzing that that you know what can I
do as an individual to affect this this
bigger this bigger problem so they don't
do anything and I don't think that's the
right perception to have I think um you
know educating yourself learning about
you know who your local prosecutor is
you know what Bill is what policies are
being put in place just those little
things voting you know as extreme this
election year that's very very important
to be able to have your voice make a
real difference and make an impact so
those are the type of conversations the
type of thinking that we want to provoke
after after watching this film in a now
manipulative way you know this is it's
not a movie that we want to play on
emotions we want to propose a question
and impose a conversation and hopefully
you know the work that Andrew and Dustin
did with writing and crafting this
script and the job that Jaime and the
one of all the other phenomenal actors
in his movie did and the amazing editing
job that that we were able to kind of
put that on on screen that Sanders
Andrew Lanham Jamie Foxx Michael B
Jordan Academy thank you